do you think Kanye could win
I think you could yeah
do you think they could reconcile Trump
and Kanye yeah do you think Trump would
I don't know because he is very uh
vengeful and spiteful and stubborn
but yeah I I don't know I mean I think
if it worked out a certain way how crazy
would it be would Kanye ever be a VP to
Trump
I would I don't think so I don't think
Trump would ever be a VP to Kanye no
problem no he like it's too much of a
ego thing yeah but I was like I almost
think Kanye
oh my gosh I'm sorry yay I can't I'm
sorry
um but I almost think yay would
it would be so interesting to see both
of them on a ticket yeah and I think yay
would say yes to that before Trump would
I'm not saying I think either of them
would but if I had to put like guess one
would before the other because he could
run for president the year after yeah
couldn't he yeah because he's young
enough and everything but no I mean yay
people know he wants to be the president
I mean he there's no campaign he hasn't
announced anything so I you know I don't
have any breaking news on that front but
uh and I think that he is a Visionary
leader like he he truly is a Visionary
and
he's not a politician so he doesn't he
doesn't know the ins and outs of the you
know the the political scene or whatever
but he's got ideas that
that can change the world and he thinks
about politics in a way that makes
political people feel stupid like he
makes me feel stupid he asks me
questions and makes me feel like an
idiot right but that's why you'd almost
because they're both Geniuses in
different ways I would love to see them
on the same time they should work
together yeah but it's more of
it's almost like an ego like whose ego
is gonna yeah because I I think both of
them
would have a hard time being a vice
president yeah that's true
yeah I don't think either of them are
interested it's just I almost could see
yet because he could run after you know
right Trump really couldn't he's too old
yeah but yay at least and that would
almost get him in the door where he
actually is political experience not
that he needs it you know he could I
think he could win either way I think
you know entertainers are the new
politicians and I don't think we're
really going to see that Trend change
yeah yeah it was true with Trump you
know Trump was an Entertainer
so yeah I mean
what's it been like working with yay
outside of that it's honestly it's
amazing because the guy is just a force
and people don't realize it but
and I know other I don't know any other
celebrities but I imagine other
celebrities I mean they all do work but
I also Imagine they they like to go and
party and they like to do the drugs and
stuff like that
yay is obsessed with everything like he
wakes up early and he works all day like
literally 18 hours barely sleeps wakes
up and from the moment he wakes up he's
going like one time
you know uh we had just finished it was
a really long day
and you know I was exhausted I was on my
way back to the hotel and before I
walked through the door my hotel he
calls me and he goes hey uh what time
are you waking up tomorrow how long you
need to sleep he knows I'm like I I
don't know six hours he goes okay I woke
up I think like six and a half hours
later he had called me 15 minutes before
literally called me six hours after I
hung up the phone because he maybe he
went to bed for a little while and he
was like I'll be at your hotel in 15
minutes that's when he picked me up and
we went to uh to Infowars and we did
Alex Jones so it's literally these like
18-hour days doesn't stop even like with
Mar-A-Lago
we
we had a super long day that Monday
the night before we woke up at the crack
of dawn the next day so barely slept
flew to Miami drove to Mar-A-Lago did
the dinner got on a private jet flew
back to LA then we got back to LA we
went to yay's hotel room and talked for
another three hours
like and then we went and then started
again the next day early again so
the the work ethic is nuts and the thing
is you know we're in his office and and
he's doing everything all at once so
we're at a table doing politics and then
he's got all these clothes on the floor
and he's got his seamstresses and his
designers and so we'll go and do
political for 30 minutes and then it'll
go look at the close and then it'll you
know he'll make decisions about clothes
then then he'll
then he'll read out like lyrics that he
wrote like that song he released the um
what what is it uh someday we'll all be
free he just released uh during all that
controversy like one day just came in
and said oh I wrote this last night and
he he literally had just written that
you know in the middle of everything
boom and then we were at another hotel
and he just cranked that out while we
were having a political meeting while he
was doing a meeting about the donda
school while he was having a business
meeting while he was so
I mean he really is like this
renaissance man like Da Vinci like I
used to think that was a little bit of
an exaggeration like I knew he was a
brilliant uh producer and I knew he was
a brilliant artist and the fashion
speaks for itself it's like everybody's
ripping off the Yeezy slides in the 350s
so I thought yeah like he's clearly a
super talented you know brilliant person
with great ideas
but when he would say I'm the greatest
artist ever I'd be like well you know I
don't know but then you're with him and
it's like nope he's around he is
literally a renaissance man and he
literally is involved because I imagine
so many artists you know there they have
guys that write their songs or guys and
make their beats and you know they're
really not super involved they just kind
of put their name on it basically like
Trump putting his name on a hotel
but no I mean he's 45 years old and he's
and he's more ambitious and driven and
hard-working than ever and the other
thing is
creative completely open we'll hear all
ideas say things that everyone in the
room will say and dismiss and say oh
that's crazy oh that's never been done
before
and he fires those people and says no
like well tell me you know what would it
be like if we did that tell me how we
can do that I think that's why he's so
Innovative because he'll he'll go in a
direction that is totally unexpected and
maybe unconventional and maybe even
people think it's crazy and he'll just
he'll take it there and go there and try
it out and sometimes that's where you
strike gold sometimes that's where you
find the the Gap hoodie or the the 350s
or that's where you find
graduation you know so
um so he he is an incredible person and
people say that he's crazy
he is completely Lucid he's hilarious
that's one of the understated things is
one of the most genuinely laugh out loud
funny people I've ever met and I'm a
funny I think I'm a funny guy I'm very
picky most people I don't find funny he
is one of the funniest people I know
just like effortlessly great sense of
humor
so he's all around a wonderful person
you know really and it's such a shame
he's been vilified because and I also
I'm very saddened by the fact there's
all these parasitic journalist types I
got ambushed by a BBC journalist sorry I
know it's a run-on I'm rambling a little
but there is this journalist who
ambushed me and said you know you're
exploiting him he's clearly unwell
you're exploiting him
and you know not only is that not true
but it's a little offensive because one
he's fully in control and two
I genuinely have such an admiration and
respect for him and I'm one of the only
guys that didn't get fired on his team
because I feel like I'm the only one
that went out there and said like I'm
here to fulfill your vision like I'm
here to you're the genius I'm the
student you made
10 11 incredible Studio albums you you
know change the streetwear game you're
the guy I'm here to learn from you and
do what you want to do and for people to
say oh you expl you're exploiting him or
those are your ideas
it couldn't be further from the truth so
anyway so that's what it's like working
with them